yeah i'm a lapsed militant atheist
i definitely not militant um definitely
not an atheist i i wouldn't say i'm
extremely religious but i i am kind of
returned to the catholicism that i i
rejected
um
it's it's a it's it's a journey i mean
after you've been marinating and and you
know the four horsemen for 10 years it's
you know you kind of have to
you have to kind of make yourself
available to to the metaphysical in a in
a very forceful way because you know
it's you know i've seen i've kind of
marinated in these arguments for a long
time um
but
i i am much more connected to to the
world of the spiritual and i think it's
it's less so that i'm you know i've read
you know a book on catholicism and i was
like well i'm struck by it by the truth
of the word of god um it was more that
i've started to doubt rationality
um i kind of started to that because
essentially what new atheism is is there
is it kind of has a religious component
it's essentially the cult of the
homunculus you know the the the rational
individual behind the eyes making all
the decisions you know
going ahead doing didn't you know
kicking ass taking names all that stuff
um and i started to doubt that figure or
that entity as being you know as good as
i thought it was or at least being being
the measure of all things and enough to
to to rule the world through um and then
you know i've kind of become a bit more
interested in tradition you know i've
tried on to see what it feels like to to
not have to
i don't know reinvent the wheel every
time you know got married and now and
i'm gonna have a baby all sorts of you
know weird old school stuff
that people used to do back in the day
and it feels really nice i have to say
so in a way kind of i'm just i'm just
you know riding blind through this whole
you know kind of almost traditional
lifestyle you know pickling and making
bread and doing all sorts of old school
stuff and it's pretty nice i don't know
i'm probably not doing it correctly or
i'm larping or whatever but
uh the closer i got to to the lifestyle
of my i don't know my ancestors in a way
like my grandma used to live the the
calmer and better i feel so i don't know
i'm just empirically testing this day by
day
well that's one of the things i find
quite interesting about your personal
story because i think uh i i would
include myself on this a lot of people
go through the sort of 20s early 30s
period of their life
and they're doing things that aren't
making them happy but they don't
necessarily know what they're supposed
to be doing and in the modern society
they're being sold a whole bunch of
narratives about what they should be
doing and what should make them happy
and quite a lot of those things they
then find out don't make them happy
aren't contributing to to a better life
or a better future but you had
whether i don't know is it the presence
of mind or whatever it might be to go
actually i'm not
this is not good
this isn't working for me and maybe i
should try my grandma's lifestyle like
how did you
how did you know that you actually need
to change up
yeah i think of it was you know
empirical experiment i realized at one
point that i was completely incapable of
making good decisions about what would
make me happy it was just like almost
completely the opposite of what i
thought was gonna was gonna do it um you
know it was good to to to go the other
way um
in in my case i i just
i don't know i was a bit disillusioned
by by what i was seeing around me
um
and yeah i i said okay you know there
there is a reason for tradition and you
know i put it putting on my economist
hat
um i i just realized that you know
tradition is a heuristic it's you know
it's what people do because it works
because it's been robust throughout time
um and you know things like
i don't know just working with your
hands or having a garden or things like
that that are just
sound yeah sound like what what old
people do to to my generation um they
really
they
it's very hard to describe but it's you
know they fulfill
fulfill a need in me that is it's hard
to you know if i had to put all my needs
in a spreadsheet i would not necessarily
know how to describe it in words or you
know to assign weights or values to it
uh but it does something you know and um
you know also
pregnancy like when i was younger i
couldn't even conceive of the idea of
having children it seemed absolutely
clear to me that i would never have
children it's absurd i don't like babies
whatever but now you know being going
through this process
it's one of those things where you don't
know what you don't have until it's
there
and yeah i think that's probably the the
issue with people being able to predict
what's going to make them happy you
really don't know until until it happens
and then you know until until you make a
commitment to something as well i think
that that's also an important dimension
because
like i said a lot of modern
living is about optionality it's about
increasing how many options you have
okay what what can i consume today
what's going to be status enhancing for
me what's what what am i getting out of
this
but a lot of the interesting things in
life a lot of the things that are hard
to put into words happen
when
you give up on options when you commit
to something you know when you commit
you know to doing this show to having a
family to building something more
long-term with someone to a friendship
or or something like that so
i feel like
we tend to optimize for the things that
we feel you know at an expedient level
are gonna make us happy which
anything from from sweets to i don't
know
impulsive sexual encounters are gonna
fit the bill
but it's very hard to predict the the
longer term stuff
and
alex do you think a large part of this
was brought on by covid because i'll
tell you from my experience so
when i was doing comedy i was gigging
six nights a week i was gigging in you
know the best clubs and you know it took
me a long time to get to that point i
thought i was happy i thought this is
what i wanted to do then overnight
life literally stopped like that and
then you're left with me exactly
and what you actually realize is that
you've been dedicating your life to a
career
but the reality is that isn't fulfilling
it's nebulous it's something it doesn't
anchor you like a family you know a
relationship etc etc was that part of
the process for you
um i think i was definitely on the path
before covet but it it has cemented it
much much more because um for example i
mean i i was
i was engaged before covid and we we got
married during covet and one of these
ridiculous ceremonies but uh um
and we wanted to have a child before
that and i was kind of you know i was
pickling before covid i have to say
but uh it did really um it strengthened
my relationship a lot you know to be in
a bunker with someone for what is it now
14 months and to to to feel like you
know you still kind of like them it's
quite cool um so there's a reassuring of
confidence for your husband that you
still kind of like him yeah yeah he's
he's okay
he's still he still kind of likes me it
seems so yeah we're tolerating each
other well
um and you know i've moved back to to
romania where we live in kind of a
duplex thing with my mom's my neighbor
and you know i see her every day and
we've had quite a rocky relationship but
it's it's really improved things and i
don't know it's it's kind of
refocused me a little bit on on the as i
said the longer term stuff the stuff
that i have more skin in the game in
um you know like family and um yeah and
in a way it's also given me a a lot of
freedom like you know the the podcast
and you know coming onto shows like this
is quite cool i'd never thought i'd i'd
be in the situation where you know
people would ask me to respond to
questions it's fun um so
yeah it's it's been it's been a
transformative time obviously it's it's
been it's not been great in many other
respects you know it's been rocky but i
think for me and a lot of people i know
so many people who are pregnant now who
are just you know decided to have
coveted babies and
you know the media says oh no it's it's
a it's a sink but i don't know i've i
don't know i'm gonna believe my lying
eyes to think that you know there's
quite a few a few covered babies popping
up so um yeah i think you know it's been
it's been a mixed blessing for sure
[Music]